[Música]
es tal vez uno de los castillos más
elegantes del renacimiento son un uso
una maravilla del siglo XVI
delicadamente ubicado en el Shrek tras
bastidores un centenar de personas de
Navidad diariamente es el encargado de
abrir el castillo desde hace 37 años es
una residencia antigua helada durante el
invierno y sofocante durante el verano
para airearla hay que abrir 60 ventanas
el castillo porque la temperatura
aumenta cada vez más y en el castillo
hace mucho calor
Todo debe estar en su lugar antes de las
9 de la mañana y la apertura Los
visitantes para embellecerlo gigantescos
Ramos le dan fama al castillo en el
mundo entero
cada semana estos dos floristas los
crean esta composición pesa 30 kilos
ocupará un lugar de honor en una de las
seis habitaciones
el lugar más conmovedor es esta
minúscula oficina desde donde kather
kingdomesis gobernó Francia hace cerca
de 500 años
había guerras por todas partes
muy calmado
tranquilo es la combinación entre los
falsos y la calma es la historia
[Música]
de mujeres que le vale un sobrenombre el
castillo de las damas construido en el
siglo 16 por la arquitecta
que nace Construir la emblemática doble
galería sobre el río Su uso es una oda a
la delicadeza cuyas primeras notas
resuenan en los jardines
Nicolás es el botanista jefe en el
terreno
es mucho mantenimiento
eliminación de maleza corte hay mucho
por hacer
llegado a Francia en el 2015 Nicolás es
un norteamericano enamorado de los
jardines de la francesa este el jardín
de Jean fue un modelo para muchos otros
es uno de los primeros jardines en
Francia creado con un eje
árboles bien cortados muy ordenados
se trata del ancestro del jardín de
Versalles
los jardines son admirados por Los
visitantes pero 6000 turistas ingresan a
los entres hijos del Castillo
diariamente es el más visitado después
de versai
pero se anunció es más pequeño entonces
aquí no hay visitas guiadas para evitar
los atascos como en las columnas del
Castillo
a veces a nosotros también nos cuesta
entrar hay que esperar
este Castillo privado le pertenece a la
misma familia desde hace un siglo
ya no vive ahí los 19 espacios pueden
ser visitados bajo la supervisión de no
tocar por favor Gracias hay mucho cobre
y en cuanto se toca queda un rastro
entonces la gente del aseo debe limpiar
el cobre diariamente para quitar esas
manchas
más arriba se está cuidando un objeto
más valioso que los cobres de la cocina
atline la doradora y Jessie La
restauradora tratan de salvar un retrato
de Luis xiv y sumar como Monumental de
la madera esculpida
es una preparación a base de blanco y
gelatina de piel de conejo moldeamos las
partes que faltan esculpiéndolas incluso
Las garras que ya no existían
por su lado Jessie aplica los últimos
retoques al cuadro la principal
dificultad es encontrar los colores
originales en un retrato de 300 años
observamos con lupa incluso con
microscopio para encontrar los colores
exactos
luego sabemos que en tal o tal siglo se
usaba tal o tal color
tras varios meses de trabajo minucioso
la última etapa no es la menos delicada
el cuadro renovado de Luis xiv encuentra
de nuevo su lugar en el salón rojo del
Castillo
[Música]
creo que vendremos varias veces en el
día para verlo luego de su
rejuvenecimiento El retrato real de hace
tres siglos puede ser admirado de nuevo
por Los visitantes hasta el cierre de
las puertas a las 7 de la noche
sonoso reabrirá Mañana bajo el cuidado
permanente de los apasionados que
trabajan a su servicio Mientras tanto el
castillo de las damas preside con
serenidad las aguas del